même type
où
il
et si vous
pouvoir grâce à cet outil d'avoir
plusieurs niveaux de couleurs qui vont
aller du bleu très clair au rouge très
foncé et en fait donc le bleu va plutôt
correspondre à des coups à des
déperditions faible et le rouge à des
déperditions importante
malgré tout il ya un certain niveau
d'interprétation qui va être difficile à
effectuer par rapport à certains niveaux
un certain nature de toiture tels que
les toitures en zinc
c'est une première dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
les habitants peuvent désormais
connaître la déperdition d'énergie de
leur toiture initiatives prises dans le
cadre de sa politique de développement
durable
les mesures ont été réalisées en hiver
quand les habitations sont chauffés et
par temps clair pour réaliser ces
mesures nous disposons d'un scanner
infrarouge un capteur qui nous permet de
mesurer le rayonnement infrarouge de
tout des toitures qui est intégrée dans
un avion un avion bimoteur qui nous
permettent de voler la nuit à 500 mètres
d'altitude issus des zones urbaines
j'ai appris que
les travaux qu'on avait fait récemment
avait servi à isoler la maison et qu'on
avait un bon résultat en termes de
déperdition de chaleur donc ça ça me
conforte un petit peu dans ce qu'on a
réalisé auparavant
les saint quentinois peuvent donc
désormais s'informer sur l'isolation
thermique de leur habitat et permanences
sont organisées les 18 et 19 octobre à
l' agence locale de l'énergie
libres à eux ensuite de se rapprocher
d'un conseiller afin de trouver des
solutions pour réduire leurs dépenses
énergétiques